he said that male depression gets
treated like female depression men are
made to feel loved and accepted when
they want to feel capable and powerful
and the problem that we had there was
that you were treating male depression
and male mental health like female
depression I had a brilliant upbringing
I've got great parents great
grandparents and then I think about the
lessons that my dad taught me there's
two things that really stand out once I
rode my bike over my neighbor's lawn and
he grabbed me around the Scruff of the
neck and he said you respect other
people's property you never do that
again you go and apologize that for me
was the male role model it would be
tough be strong be respectful there's
another one and I remember when I'd done
something wrong and I was so upset and
he just sat there and he went what are
you going to do about it and that
feeling of Ben you have to be strong you
have to take control of the situation
things have to be much more tangible
what are you going to do about it I
don't want to put someone just to sit
there and stroke my ego and tell me that
everything's gonna be okay and I'm okay
the way I am because I think that over a
prolonged period of time can definitely
lead to entitlement and I don't think
it's the right thing in the long term